So, we found a bunch of huge sci-fi satellite
dish things...on the top of a mountain...in
Alaska...and they look like this!
And we just figured out why they’re there
and what they do...and it’s really weird!
Hey everyone, Amy here.
Our friends at Seeker went on a shoot to Alaska
recently, and they came back with a story
that we just had to tell on DNews.
It’s about a huge, ambitious military project
called White Alice.
By now the whole thing is barely a footnote
in the history of the Cold War...but 60 years
ago, it was revolutionary for the military,
and for Alaska.
In order to get why White Alice was so important,
you have to understand a few things about
Alaska.
First: it’s huge, it’s empty, and it’s
wild.
In the mid 1950’s, it was home to just 215,000
people, spread across an area that’s twice
the size of Texas.
That made modern communication a pretty big
hassle.
Stringing telegraph or phone lines between
cities meant crossing hundreds of miles of
rugged, usually frozen terrain.
The huge distances made radio communication
flaky; even high-frequency signals fritzed
out when the Northern Lights appeared!
This was all a big problem because, during
the Cold War, the US military needed good
comm networks in Alaska.
Pearl Harbor was still fresh in everyone’s
mind, and the government feared a far-North
sneak attack from the Soviets...remember,
Alaska and Russia are 53 miles apart at the
Bering Strait.
It’s such a narrow divide that the region
became known as the “ice curtain”.
The US and Canadian air forces set up a series
of radar listening posts along the Arctic
Ocean, but they needed a way to relay information
across the state, and fast.
And that is where White Alice came in.
Beginning in 1955, the Air Force and Army
built a network of communications hubs that
used a very new technology to connect with
one another.
Phone calls and other data were transmitted
via microwaves, beamed into the air, bounced
off the Earth’s upper atmosphere, and back
down to a receiving site.
Each hub had two sets of dishes: one set for
receiving a signal, and another for broadcasting
it back out to the next hub.
The process, called “tropospheric scattering”,
had (and still has) a lot of advantages over
other technologies.
First, bouncing signals off the upper atmosphere
means that hubs don’t need a clear line
of site to communicate...which is a useful
thing in a mountainous place like Alaska.
This way, White Alice sites could be 200 miles
apart.
The signal could also support multiple phone
calls at the same time, something few other
systems could manage.
And, crucially for the military, it was secure.
Once a signal is beamed out, it can only be
received at one exact spot - making it next
to impossible to intercept the signal along
the way.
All in all, the military built 22 tropospheric
scattering sites across Alaska, eventually
spending around $300 million dollars.
And it wasn’t alone.
Similar networks sprung up around the world
- the US even connected Hawaii to the Philippines
through the Pacific Scatter System.
But it might have had the biggest impact on
Alaska, uniting the new state in ways that
no other technology could have.
But...before White Alice was even complete,
a new technology arrived to replace it.
In 1957 the Soviets launched Sputnik 1, the
world’s first artificial satellite.
US development of satellite communications
ramped up, and by 1967, just 8 years after
the network’s completion, the government
began to divest from the very system it built.
Interestingly, White Alice remained in use
until the late ‘70s as a civilian phone
network.
And today, the military still uses tropo scattering
networks here and there...because they’re
still really secure.
But this remains the era of satellites.
Now, the reason we have all this footage is
that the White Alice hub outside of Nome still
stands today...it’s one of the last tropo
scattering sites in Alaska to escape demolition.
The electronics there are long dead, but the
structures themselves still serve a final
purpose: they’re unmistakable landmarks,
visible for miles.
And they still help hunters and travelers
out on the tundra find their way home to Nome.
Like I mentioned earlier, this story came
out of a much larger trip to the Bering Strait
- and the Seeker Daily team has a great video
about how the whole world might need the Strait
soon.
To watch that video now, click here.
And as always, thanks for watching.